[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
we like
and love
these types of people
we like high-profile
glossy
uh
people that
are are vapid
and don't have much
going on in their heads but think they
do
like they are under the impression
they have big thoughts
big big thoughts
like megan and harry i've listened to
both of them talk
garden variety retards
both of them she's hot
he's
royal
but garden variety morons either one of
them i watched megan
and i watched harry
they were using their emotion to cover
up the fact that they were not smart
they were not
too
smart
and they were obviously it was an
emotionally charged interview
because they had just left the country
uh they had found out that the royal
family is uh racist
which was shocking
um up until now they had only thought
that the the royal family uh had
murdered harry's mother
but upon
finding out that in addition to
murdering harry's mother they were also
quite insensitive on the topic of race
no good
up until that point you said well
they're just an illuminati death cult
that drink blood and live for a thousand
years and have murdered my fiance's
mother
but
we're going to give them a shot
and let's see how evolved they are and
it turns out they're not too evolved and
i watched the uh oprah interview and we
talked about it on the show they're just
not bright
so like many people
uh but they believe they are bright
they say the right things they're like
there are so many people in the world
without
yes
there are so many people in the world
without which is why we have to come to
los angeles and live in a
beautiful mansion with round-the-clock
security we got to get a deal at netflix
and make documentaries about people that
are [ __ ]
that's what it is they want to be on
netflix and make documentaries about
people with cleft palates she's a
hollywood actress means she's ambition
she has
ambition um actors are stupid people
they're not smart very few of them are
intelligent and the ones that are
intelligent are much much older young
actors are and we know many of them
they're insanely dumb to where it's
noticeable have you ever been with
someone who's so dumb it's noticeable
where you look at someone else as if to
be in disbelief at what this person is
doing
if you had lunch with meghan markle
you'd be stunned at how dumb she was not
cause she's black because i wouldn't
think she was black if i looked at her
because she's an actress who was on the
show suits
okay she's an actress harry is an idiot
he's an idiot for two reasons number one
he signed up to fight in the afghanistan
war that was a dumb move
you're a [ __ ] prince what are you
doing that [ __ ] for
number two
i know it's heroic i guess after 9 11
but i think he signed up years after
that that's hilarious and number two i
he's still believing this dumb story
that the paparazzi killed his mom maybe
he doesn't maybe just
so she gets them to leave his family she
goes she goes why do we want to stay
here and i get it i'm for them why do we
want to stay here they're racist the
weather sucks the food [ __ ]
let's go to la we'll eat sushi by the
pool every day and we'll make
documentaries about people with cleft
palates
he goes well is it is it when their face
is all yes she goes and then every now
and then we'll fly one of them over
we'll clean up their face and we'll take
them to disneyland but we got to get out
of the uk and we got to come to the us
and we're going to go on oprah and then
every idiot in america but he's like but
they're mad at rich people not our kind
of rich people
she goes i'm kind of black
and you're
an idiot
so you just and you're willing to be
emasculated so you just sit there and
eat your own [ __ ] on tv
i'll tell oprah that they were chasing
me around the royal palace with nooses
and then netflix will open up a suitcase
full of money and we'll go do
documentaries about kids with cleft
palates is it like where their lip is in
their nose yes
yes just google it harry
so that's what went on
watching people fawn over them we like
royalty we love it we like rich people
stop pretending you don't like rich
people
stop pretty the people that tweet about
marxism all day then talk about how much
they love the real housewives you just
can't quit it and nobody is a realer
housewife than meghan markle who married
this ginger [ __ ] and took him out of
his racist family so that they could
live in beverly hills or wherever the
[ __ ] they live and make documentaries
about people without hands
on netflix
netflix by the way who's committed to
just giving these people anything they
want whenever they want they're making a
cartoon what is the cartoon about
it's called pearl yes it's about a young
girl who is inspired by influential
women in history and counts david
furnish and liz garbus amongst his
executive producers
uh yeah i guess that's a
12 year old girl who's inspired by
influential women in history the series
currently in development it's all the
information we have that's it
uh she's on a journey of self-discovery
as she tries to overcome life's daily
challenges says well that sounds great
good for her man do you know how many
actresses
that do a show like suits just get
thrown off out in the street
afterwards
megan marco parlayed that
into a [ __ ] royal wedding and then a
year in or a couple of years in said
[ __ ] that [ __ ] and left and i'm not
saying the royal family was not racist
to her
i'm sure they were but that also didn't
start
when she got there
an exciting tale that weaves together
fantasy and history pearl focuses on a
young girl who learns to step into her
own power when she embarks on a heroic
adventure and meets important women from
history along the way so you know what
this is going to be like pearl's going
to go back you know there's going to be
a scene
where pearl's like
who are you
my name is harrion
harriet who
harriet tubman
we got a railroad and you go oh my god
this is the underground railroad yes it
is
this is so amazing i can't believe it
you're so brave and strong yes i am
child but i'm not nearly as brave and
strong as meghan markle
who's that she was an actress on suits
it's tv show
yeah
she married prince harry
you know the son of that woman they
killed
in a in the thing in the tunnel and they
said the press did it but you know it's
gonna cause she was gonna marry dodie
off i end he was muslim it's a whole
thing it's oil
saudi arabia whatever you gotta follow
cynthia mckinney on twitter what
anyway
i'm just saying
yes i'm where's cynthia mckinney at the
met gala by the way that all she did was
took him at 9 11 all day where is she
where is she where is she
well here's what i'm saying child
i'm saying it i may be brave but the
bravest person ever is meghan markle
thank you
i'm excited for that show that is the
message from the government if you don't
have symptoms and you've tested negative
uh you're not out of the woods so by the
way that's fun for the anxiety hopefully
nobody has anxiety one in three la
residents have been affected by
coronavirus it's a new estimate it's a
nielsen rating right we think this
amount of people are watching jersey
shore we don't know but if you have
anxiety this has been great how's in the
last year been nicer remember when we
all cared about mental health right all
of a sudden that went out the window
when the media every other day is going
are you do you feel good guess what did
you test negative guess what you got it
[ __ ]
it's real and it sucks but here's the
other thing this is a little a message
for the people that have survived it
because i've had enough
i really have had enough now with
i was in a yard yesterday two people in
the yard had had covert they hijacked
the entire
event which was not really an event it
was just a hang
they hijacked it to discuss
how they both beat coven how bad it was
and how no one in the history of the
world will ever understand the struggles
that they went through
not aids not cancer not those [ __ ]
with als
nobody will understand how hard it is to
be covered
i go i haven't had it i said i've been
being relatively careful i said i got
very sick in march i had all the
symptoms i tightness to the chest i had
chills i woke up in the middle of the
night i couldn't really leave the bed i
was exhausted i could make it from my
bed to my couch maybe i lost smell i
don't really know but i know that my
taste was all [ __ ] up i could barely
eat it took me three and a half weeks to
get my things back and then they look at
you and they go no
you didn't have it you would know if you
had it
this doesn't even feel organic it's a
bio weapon that you do battle with and
they're literally doing
like cobra kind moves in the yard about
how covered they're like you think
you're good then it hits you from the
side and then you double over and then
you have to kick and if it hits you
again and i'm like what and then i'm
like well other people get really sick
you know my friend's mother had
pancreatic cancer she fought that for 10
years and they're like [ __ ] that [ __ ] i
had covered you don't understand it's a
bio weapon they act like they defeated
the chinese military with this you can't
even get a word and edge rise with these
people you can't say that other people
get sick people die of cancer is cancer
not a thing anymore
what about aids with these [ __ ]
people
lesions all over how about ebola i mean
these [ __ ] [ __ ] will go to africa
people bleeding out of their eyes
there's lepers on the thing and they go
you don't know about coven i couldn't
taste my hot dog you don't know about
covert it's just a bio weapon
ebola is just one of those cute diseases
that comes from the nature it's not a
weapon i beat a weapon so it just gets a
little it gets a little
frustrating what is that it frost
frustrating
is doesn't it sound better as frustrated
i do like that it's quicker
this whole thing we know how bad covert
is we know how much it [ __ ] people up
i've had friends
tell me how
how how bad it has been for them both
physically and mentally i understand
that
dan carney for example my opener who's
had it is now occasionally tired
so i get i get it the point is i don't
know why i haven't gotten this but
here's what i will tell you i know that
it's really bad and vicious when people
get it in a bad and vicious way but is
one of the symptoms that you have to
discuss it for seven months afterwards
is there any let up here
because truly when you bring up any
other disease
they look at you like you don't get it
and i'm like well what about als where
you get diagnosed and you literally
become a puddle and then die within two
years they go think i'm not still no
not a bio weapon
they go you don't get they go you don't
get it this is made in a lab and i beat
it and then they tell you they're like
this is how i beat it i sat in a room
and i just went i'm gonna beat it i'm
gonna beat it i'm gonna beat it and
they're like you don't even understand
the what you go through the mental
fitness you have to ha and i'm like yeah
okay but again my friend's mother
fought a death sentence pancreatic
cancer for 10 years it's unheard of the
woman was out doing marches she was
raising money there are people that
overcome
horrible conditions there are people
born with horrible conditions okay
okay
so this idea that the only thing in the
world
that anyone the the the mark of a man is
that he beat covert
the mark of a man the mark of the
soldier
they're acting
and i know it's bad but the way that
they're talking and acting makes me feel
so much less sympathetic for them
because it's getting obnoxious it's
obnoxious to tell a group of people that
somehow they're less than because they
didn't beat what they're calling a
chinese bio weapon these are the people
by the way that have had it
they're like china tried to take hong
kong with this bio weapon
i beat it
but it's tough how about ala get als up
that's a walk in the park apparently
because you're covered let's get als up
muscle cramps tight and stiff muscles
slurred in nasal speech difficulty
chewing or swallowing which which ends
up no chewing or swallowing okay
literally what it does is it immobilizes
you oh and it's insane how bad it is
okay
difficulty swallowing drooling lack of
restraint mild cognitive impairment
severe constipation unintentional weight
loss shortness of breath difficulty
raising your foot so you bring this up
to these people and they go dude you
don't even get it
you don't even [ __ ] get it dude this
is like lab made it's something else
something different it's just
annoying
it's just annoying and it's got to stop
i know it's bad but it's got to stop
life
is a pandora's box of
horror
okay
people have all kinds of problems
some people's problems are greater than
others some people have to go through
horrible things
okay
i understand that this can be an insane
life-changing event for people it could
be a horrible thing it could kill them
it could kill me
i've been open and honest about that but
what we don't want to do is annoy people
to death as well
by by pretending that you are the only
thing that matters and that the things
that you've gone through are the only
things that anyone should ever take
seriously
that everybody else in this country
that's suffering because we have an
opioid epidemic or because their jobs
have evaporated or because they don't
have health insurance okay or that they
work all week for [ __ ] wages and nobody
cares about them and they have to
[ __ ] navigate this world without any
help from anybody those people should
all shut the [ __ ] up because you hadn't
got sick i had covered
okay
i don't want to hear about your
hemorrhagic fever your ebola
boo
i just did a little fake business now
you know that i do this a lot of the
audience don't know that i do i do fake
business
i call up realtors all day when i'm
bored
and i pretend i'm a realtor and that my
client is very interested in their
property and i ask them lots of
questions about their property i just
did it with a commercial property on
palm canyon drive i said hey this is tim
uh i have a client of investor that's
really interested in the property what
are we looking at per square foot and
what are some of the local restrictions
we should know about and you know these
whole things they go into this whole
thing they go well you know they don't
want a coffee shop in there because
starbucks there's a competing business
clause so starbucks doesn't want a
coffee shop this is how the corporate
takeover of america is by the way
because when starbucks moves into an
area they go yeah we don't need we don't
want some independent coffee shop
opening not all areas but a lot of them
we don't need somebody slinging lattes
for less than we are so the guy goes
well there's a sprint store so we can't
do a competing business blah blah blah
and we talked about it there's a lot of
parking behind i said thank you i said i
have an investor but he's very concerned
about you know the competing business
clause and everything like that i was on
the phone with this guy for about 10
minutes and he said to me oh tim that's
cruel their time has value no it doesn't
and i will continue to do fake business
because i enjoy i like doing fake
business it's one of my favorite things
to do i like to call people and i like
to lie
about who i am and and and what i do
and then i like to see how they conduct
business because on their end they're
conducting real business i'm conducting
fake business now never the two shall
meet we've gotten to the point where i
was we're almost one of my clients who
doesn't exist was almost going to put an
offer on a house this was last week i
was i've been on the phone with this
realtor for like 45 minutes three times
in a row i've had the blocker finally
she doesn't know what happened
sometimes i have to block the people
because fake business gets very intense
fake business people start drawing up
contracts i mean she was calling
appraisers she was gonna have
inspections done you know i was
representing a very motivated overseas
client now sadly that client died of
coronavirus before we could go see the
property that's not my fault and i tried
to explain that to her but she was kind
of confused and started saying oh this
you know blah blah blah
are you real is this real
cops fbi whatever blah blah blah blocked
blocked
i'm helping train these professionals
do you understand yes or yes
i by calling them
people need practice
so this schmuck over there on palm
canyon i did use my real name by the way
like this is tim dillon
and sometimes i make up a firm name
sometimes i use a real firm name
sometimes i just say this is tim dill
with futures
he goes what i got futures investment
he goes okay
you just go okay
go yeah all right
i go yeah you got a commercial listing
on palm canyon on the corner i'm
wondering what we're looking at price
per square foot what's the parking in
the area like what's the competing
business clause
any local restrictions we should know
about i have a team of investors that
are looking to expand into this area
many of them uh sometimes it's a
franchise sometimes not
but i'm just you know it's an investment
group they're very interested they love
the visibility of the location oh he
goes it's a great location so they love
the visibility of the look and see right
there we're beginning to do
fake business
because then he goes to his wife he goes
i just got a call from a guy that may be
interested in this and then he tells the
secretary and then he tells his partner
so i'm in
i'm in and i'll give him a follow-up
call later tonight i'll have 10 more
bullet point questions
before i bring my investors and i do
this a lot of people
[Music]
i was explaining to someone at dinner
that i did i do this
and it goes it's horrible i said why
i'm doing fake business
they go why i said i like doing it
because i don't have a real estate
license and i can't do real business but
i at least can do fake business
they said that's pretty sick
i said maybe you're sick
because i want realtors to get the best
professional i want your golf a lot
right
when you golf when you golf every day
are you better at it yes absolutely
now that doesn't matt now even that
includes going to a driving range sure
right
correct right sometimes i see golfers
swing clubs in their backyard
helps helps
doesn't matter if it's real or fake what
matters is that this guy's going through
the moat the next guy to call him might
be real
but i'm going to beat that guy out
i'm gonna do a competitive offer
hello hey adam tim dillon how are you we
spoke about the property on palm canyon
a few minutes ago yeah hey tim how's it
going good buddy how are you i wanted to
know if there's a list of
the the competing clause uh my client's
asking me if there's a list of
businesses whether it's starbucks sprint
things like that that we could kind of
figure out
what the restrictions are just so i
could kind of email that to them because
he wants to show it to the his investors
if that's possible also is there a way
they can get out to see the proper
property maybe later in the
week yeah yeah i live about four minutes
from it so not too difficult um
that and um
uh i will just go to the center right
now and send you a quick list of all the
businesses that are
i would appreciate that let me ask you a
question too how long has this probably
been on the market i have i haven't
looked it up yet
yeah i've been marketing it for maybe
i think
i just signed it like right when covet
hit and then i delayed it for like two
or three months so i think maybe like
two or three months now
okay and before you had it was it was it
sitting there for a while or no they
always like to know these things
yeah i don't i know banner mattress was
there up until recently
um
so
i know there's a mattress
right across the street yeah i saw that
is this would this be a five year lease
or what do we what are they looking for
in terms of commitment
yeah really just depends on the the
tenant and the rate and things like that
obviously the longer the the commitment
the better we can do on the rate um but
um you know i think they're open right
now okay and i imagine that i'm in five
years i imagine they're open to some
form of negotiation
at you know given the climate
of course okay well i appreciate that
we're here to do deals yeah me too but i
mean me too
it's a little wild out there you know
are you guys mainly commercial you do
any residential
um i'll do a bit of both okay good yeah
you got to be kind of a generalist out
here i i agree a lot of people are
starting to get interested in this area
and i think it's because you know la's
had a lot of problems and a lot of a lot
of my clients i do business primarily in
in in los angeles and a lot of people
are starting to look at this area
and um you know a lot of them are are
excited about maybe jumping into
uh something here you know because the
high season i imagine it's what january
through through june
uh yeah january through april is our
high high season right um but we're
pretty much like right now like
september through april um you know so
we have kind of we kind of have like a
shoulder mid-season uh which is
september through december right um and
then january april just crushes and then
uh coachella is obviously in stagecoach
earned april and that kind of
you know and we have in memorial day
weekend july 4th and during the summer
we do pretty well of course i appreciate
that well listen i have you guys i have
your website i'm going to shoot you an
email
um just again introducing myself and
then if you could just get me a list of
some of those competing business clauses
just so i can show it to them
and uh hopefully they'll get out to see
it sometime uh next week you know
they're they're super interested one of
them lives out here in rancho and uh
they pass it all the time so they had me
just kind of reach out to you and see
what was going on but they're pretty
motivated and again i think it's all
about you know how restrictive those
clauses are
yeah i think they're going to be pretty
flexible so i'll shoot you the
businesses yes and uh we'll see if we
can do something okay i appreciate it
adam thanks a lot for your time
all right thank you
so it's fake business
and i'm doing it well
i'm doing it well let's be honest i'm
doing it well i'm protecting the
interests of my clients
am i not
am i not protecting the interests of my
clients when i conduct fake business
my fake clients are important and they
need to be protected
i want them to have the maximum amount
of freedom
in any given situation
you understand
start doing fake business it'll change
your life i'm telling you that right now
start doing it
no one can start you don't need a
license
you just need a phone
and a computer and you can start doing
fake business set up a fake email
address i have one
start doing fake business right now it's
the gateway to real business i've done
nothing you understand i do not get bad
reviews on airbnb because i treat people
with respect
now
let's describe
let's describe some of the issues
number one i went i was told i was going
to a luxury compound in joshua tree
luxury means something very specific to
me
okay it doesn't mean
necessarily
stylized high concept and artistic it
means luxury it means
fluffy couches and nice carpets luxury i
feel luxurious
you understand
um
we went to a nice
thing in joshua tree which is the place
where all people in the tech industry go
to take mushrooms and people that work
for ice go and have you know to take dmt
and figure out how to build stronger
cages to put kids in you know it's great
it's for people having revelations so we
go to joshua tree which is really just
it's a litter box for drug addicts let's
be honest it's a litter box for drug
addicts and i know that a lot of people
like it but that's what it is and that's
who you are
so we get into the house the house
the furniture in the house is like
it's all it's all of course these are
two white women i believe they're
lesbians i don't want to i say that
they're lesbians i don't know but their
names are stupid like one of them's
name's mila it's like it's a stupid name
you're a ridiculous person okay you
accuse me of breaking a cactus how do
you even do that you goofy [ __ ] shut
the [ __ ] up
okay you slob
so i walk into your [ __ ] house which
you can't even sit on the [ __ ] front
i got fat people here they're 400 pounds
how are they gonna sit on your cowhide
chair that's a little thin thing of
[ __ ] leather what are we supposed to
do this guy's 900 pounds what are we
gonna do here okay
every piece of furniture can't sodomize
the guest you have to have some [ __ ]
chair that works like an actual [ __ ]
chair throw a beanbag in there okay not
everybody's a 90-foot 90-pound lesbian
on ayahuasca that can perch on a [ __ ]
bird cage for the whole night okay you
freaks listen the [ __ ] up
talking to you
people are gonna rent your house that
are actual people that need actual
furniture to actually sit
not everything's a [ __ ] trip to
hyperspace
there's actual 3d reality that some of
us have to [ __ ] live in
so we went there
and we do nothing to the furniture we we
literally don't damage any of the
furniture they have these kitchen stools
that are concrete slabs
mila
mila we work so hard for the shut up
get a job
there are concrete slab
kitchen chairs high top kitchen chairs
okay
that are like art pieces these are not
chairs and they have little stools that
are made out of what what was that like
hollowed out so like marble or the the
marble petrified wood petrified wood or
i don't know what it was
it's a little stool
that you're supposed to sit it's a tiny
little table
where your ass can't even fit on this
small little thing of wood that you have
to sit on
and eat i don't even know what right
so
they just want you doing drugs do you
walk in as a big mortar and a pestle
there i know like just crush it up
just crush it up and do it get it into
the butcher and that's fine listen i got
it i got janja
tagged the shrimps but some people want
to have a nice meal there
we treated that house that could have
never been treated it was wholesome
american
food
we went to vons
in the desert and we got burgers and
bushes baked beans and we cooked baked
beans and yes beans explode when they're
hot yeah
whose fault is that i didn't come up
with the idea for the bean
they explode without and then we wanted
uh gordon's fish we got the gorton's
fish which is very nice the breaded
pre-breaded gordon's fish and some
tartar sauce so we so
baked beans
gorton's fish with tartar sauce
cheeseburgers and then seven pints of
ice cream so we could try yeah
just have a little ice cream testing
and we left a few dishes
in the sink in the sink a pot of
exploded beans
an extra tartar sauce i didn't even use
that i said you can use
um
some ice cream i mean the smell of the
house was fish and bean yeah
but that's not my fault you couldn't
have a cleaning because she's like the
cleaning crew complained what what is it
my fat maid over there probably
complaining but it's like well why are
they complaining they're supposed to be
cleaning their job is to clean
okay
so this [ __ ] then texts me she goes our
cleaning crew had a heart attack lol so
i'm like okay and then she goes but
please give us a good review should we
stay on airbnb so here's the deal with
airbnb we review each other we don't
know what we've said if you're gonna
come reach out to me and ask me for good
review and acknowledge that the cleaning
crew was like oh we got to wash some
dishes i'm like okay they're not mad we
didn't do anything there's some dishes
in the sink but it is what it is i paid
a 400 cleaning fee you stupid content
jonah and mila you [ __ ] pigs i'll
burn your [ __ ] house down by the way
anyway i texted them that i texted them
i was gonna burn their house down and i
sent them a gif of the simpsons house
burning i'm like i know where your house
is they're like are you threatening me
i'm like let's just see what happens i'm
like stay safe out there you stupid
desert dykes
anyway
so i responded to her by saying no one
broke anything your house sucks
because she said i was a bad guy and
then and then people are like did this
really happen it can't really happen
i said the few the furniture is unusable
you're not artist your home is wildly
overpriced true you begged me for good
rating and then trashed me the cleaning
crew complained about cleaning who's
your cleaning crew
there were some dishes that is all
i don't really care about your reviews i
don't rent up my home to strangers like
an animal good luck with everything in
the future the place is a dump and it
looks like it was furnished by drug
addicts which i imagine you are please
get the help you need if you want me to
take you to an a.a meeting or an n a
meeting i will go to ikea get some
actual furniture which hopefully you can
afford not everything has to be an art
piece and feel free to use the tartar
sauce i left behind later pig and that's
what i wrote to them on airbnb and no
response and then i and then i sent a
few that could have been considered
quasi-threatening messages but they were
not threats they were an art piece like
your furniture they're not meant to be
sat on or taken literally i was doing an
art piece
you see
it was all a metaphor
and an angry it angered me because she
[ __ ] on me publicly on airbnb which
anyone can see
truly and now i look like the bad guy
i look like the bad guy [ __ ] you
we didn't do anything
dishes were in the sink the hot tub
wasn't hot you already paid 400 for a
clean if we're not supposed to eat the
gordon's fish why would they sell it at
the supermarket
i'm not getting fresh fish i trust the
gorton's fisherman yeah and it's a
lovely if you've ever had a gorton's
they're lovely very good and then the
mccormick tartar sauce goes very well
with it it pairs very well
i'm sorry i wasn't doing speed balls in
your bathroom like the rest of your
guests
you [ __ ] pigs
you've done nothing but create a [ __ ]
satanic vortex for people to sin
and i didn't take part in it i made
bowls of baked beans
[Music]
i'll i will not toler i will not
tolerate
being disparaged publicly like that
and this good man
does he he did nothing wrong he slept in
a room where the sun
hit him directly in the face as soon as
it came up because there were no [ __ ]
curtains yeah because curtains are too
basic for these [ __ ]
hoes and i hope they hear this by the
way i hope someone in your garbage life
shows you this podcast you are nothing
do you understand me you clowns look at
your airbnb picture you're you pose with
your [ __ ] dogs you're clowns you're
not interesting and you were not an
artist you are failures and you were
drug addicts and i'm telling you right
now if you had any clue the holy hell
that was about to rain down on you
you would [ __ ] run you would have you
would run out into the desert and
sacrifice yourself because every day i
swear to christ every [ __ ] day i wake
up and i think about how to destroy you
in that [ __ ] and i'll figure it out
and see this is what i mean about the
cops can't call me out on this because
it's my right to kind of vent these
frustrations and i can't because they
can't knock on my door and say hey did
you say you're gonna kill these two
dykes and joshua tree i can't this is
what i mean do you see in real time i'm
proving my point from the beginning of
the show that's why the show is
entertaining and it's informative
because the reality is we're all having
these thoughts all the time because what
i really want to do is gas these two in
their house and watch them just
i want to watch them [ __ ] climb over
their shitty art house furniture and get
to the [ __ ] door and just just
they can't get any breath and then fall
and then just walk in and i want to piss
on their corpses but i'm not going to do
that i'm not
going to do that
i'm just going to talk about it do you
understand the difference i put that up
and i said today is my birthday i want
to thank my parents for all their
support this is what you created enjoy
it and
my aunt
wrote a comment
and the comment let's not find it
and the comment was and my cousin sent
me the comment my con the comment was
the saddest part is that you have your
grandfather's name and you don't care at
all and you care nothing about his
legacy
very very nasty comment
very very nasty comment and you know me
i hate to bring family drama on the show
i hate that
you know i don't do it we can get this
down
i i really don't do it okay
uh my aunt kathleen by the way okay
uh
comes from me
on instagram
brings up my grandfather and insults me
on the day of my birth
now let's get something straight you bum
[ __ ]
didn't you fake a drug overdose
didn't you fake a suicide attempt i
keenly remember
you
faking that you overdosed on drugs and
you were taken to a hospital in an
ambulance in front of your mother
who had just dealt with grandpa's death
what part of grandpa's legacy were you
honoring with that behavior what part of
it do you remember that i remember you
going to a hospital and then having the
entire family go worried about you not
me but other people because i know what
you're up to you clown [ __ ]
they went to the hospital and said what
drugs is she on doctor and the doctor
goes there are no drugs in her system
she literally
pretended to be unconscious so then an
ambulance went to the home
put her in it and drove her to the
hospital
scaring her mother half to death
grandpa's legacy
okay what part of grandpa's legacy were
you thinking about when you took his
money for law school and then never
practiced law and were fired multiple
times by multiple law firms all over
long island because you're mentally ill
forcing
uh your father to set up a pretend law
office for you in your basement that you
pretend to be a lawyer in
you added a phone line to the house
to pretend to be an attorney
what part of the legacy is that
what part of the legacy is borrowing
money from your more successful brothers
and sisters and not paying any of it
back while you sit around the house
doing percocet and drinking white wine
what part of the legacy is that are you
honoring his days as a carpenter
is that what you're honoring by sitting
around and getting junked up on the
couch
pretending to ot and by the way the life
you live you don't even have to pretend
okay you can't even do that right so i'm
just wondering why you would bring up my
grandfather i have all the respect in
the world for a legendary character
patriarch of an amazing family rose from
poverty did all these things why come on
my instagram and say anything negative
and and bring up a guy who every day
with your life and your choices
where is his legacy in mind kathleen and
i know you watch this okay in between
reading cue drops and letting fox news
broil your already viking and adult
brain okay
it's the wrong day kathleen i'm the
wrong one you know that i blocked you on
the family uh i i got a new phone
together the family [ __ ] group text
cause you kept texting people about all
the dishes they have to do when they
come to the family parties [ __ ] no
one's coming anymore no one cares i
don't want to be near you you should be
in a padded room how my mother is in an
asylum and you have somehow escaped it
is beyond me and it's beyond everybody
you are a disgrace
drug addict potentially closeted lesbian
you've never moved out of the house
nobody respects you you are a pedophile
probably you are gross around kids
nobody wants you [ __ ] taking baths
with their [ __ ] kids you're a [ __ ]
weirdo they gotta watch you like [ __ ]
epstein
so don't f keep my name out of your
mouth okay pedophile drug addict
this is the fake business mug
and the fake business mug
uh is is not on sale anymore
oh it is for sale until the 28th yeah so
you don't work you don't have a family
you steal money you fake drug overdoses
you're a moral degenerate you you you
have no respect for people you drive
wedges in between people in the family
and you attack successful people in the
family
my grandfather did none of those things
he was a devoutly religious incredibly
generous brilliant
hard worker who raised an entire family
you are the exact opposite of all of
those things all of those things
okay
every one of them
i blocked you i got a new phone to get
out of the group chat because i didn't
want to deal with your constant
terrorism or updating me like hey uh
little tom got his license who hey who
gives a [ __ ] dummy get a job get a
[ __ ] job i have a job why don't you
get a job stop worrying about who got
their license nobody wants you neither
family
you [ __ ] freak where's your man [ __ ]
where's your woman where's anything
what are you doing
i mean let let's get real
i mean this is a woman who does nothing
but it but attack attack attack and by
the way
[ __ ]
my fam and i like some of them
but and then my aunt goes like this uh
she goes like this she goes
she goes oh you know if i bump she's
told this to somebody else because if i
bumped into him i'd really give him a
piece of my mind how are you gonna bump
into me [ __ ] i don't live in your
kitchen okay
you've never left you've never left home
i'm in malibu oh how am i gonna bump
into you okay
buying tampax at the local cvs for your
barren childless vagina how would we
ever bump heads together keep my name
out of your mouth
scumbag
you're a degenerate you're a moral
this isn't even a podcast anymore i'm
talking directly to you
you are a failure and a moral degenerate
okay
come pig from a sketch a few years ago
on my chest is a funny dumb joke you my
friend are a disgusting
nightmare that nobody wants to be around
you're a thief you've stolen people's
money haven't you kathleen you've stolen
money haven't you
you know you have where's the money
kathleen did you take it
you took all the money didn't you and
then you go cry and some people have
family like you're being too hard on her
[ __ ] you too
hey [ __ ] you
too you think i give a [ __ ] about any of
you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
i have a family okay it's joe rogan and
candace owens my mother and father
give a [ __ ] about you [ __ ] clowns go
do a [ __ ] irish step dance i don't
give a [ __ ] this [ __ ] is out of her
[ __ ] mo you are out of your mind
just bringing my grandfather my
instagram trying to trying to knock me
like that it's a shitty thing to do
especially from you who's accomplished
zero in your entire [ __ ] life and i i
would be worried that you'd sue me but
you don't know how to practice law
you're not a real lawyer are you
because you work from a basement and you
have pretend clients you set up a care
bear you had from when you were [ __ ]
nine and you still have because you
never left your house and you go hello
mr care bear did you have a dewy well
let's look at your options
you're a clown [ __ ]
no one takes you seriously you should be
getting electroshock therapy that's kind
of how i wanted to start off the show
okay that's it for this video honorable
mention to the gates of hell and the
night of the beating those weren't
videotaped so couldn't really include
them in this video but here's one more
rant for you go follow joker rolled on
instagram we have these free stickers
for everyone that dm's us go follow us
dude there's 7 000 people following on
instagram and 56 000 following on
youtube that doesn't make sense we're
posting very similar stuff on instagram
than we are on youtube get over there i
don't know how to get you guys over
there this is my rant this is my only
rant go follow us get these free
stickers just dm us your address and you
get these stickers you can put them
anywhere you want do you have stuff that
is ugly
look it makes it better you can put them
on your friends you can put them on stop
signs water bottles laptops your [ __ ]
it doesn't matter go get these stickers
go follow us on instagram that's it have
a great day
[Music]
you